hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
it's John Humphrey / thor ragnarok we
have our tickets for next week there's
this featurette out called meet the
revenge errs oh boy I figured let's get
to know the revenger 'he's a little bit
let's just keep him finding out more and
more and not be surprised by anything
although I gotta say oftentimes with
Marvel movies when I keep seeing footage
I'm like I don't want anything ruin for
me but you always enjoyed it but then
yeah I always enjoy the clips and when I
watch the movie I'm always surprised
yeah like they do a decent job of not
putting the whole thing oh yeah they'll
show you what one of the surprises is
but not everything surprising about it
and today's page for the day shout out
it's gonna go out to Tony McGuire keep a
lookout bud see McGee
[Music]
and he is
[Music]
oh yeah dude this looks it's too bad
after going around Tomatoes I saw just
how terrible the reviews are for this 9%
9%
let's watch it on the screen right there
9% yeah apparently the visuals are very
very boring yeah and Chris Hemsworth is
just not interesting it's not even
really his movie you know it's kind of
bleak I hear hella is a terrible villain
easily the worst out of the air test the
Thompsons nothing special it's too bad
this films a disappointment we make
ourselves laughing that sounds really
cool I mean one thing that I've been
hearing a lot of people really rave
about a hella and B Valkyrie fee like
Tessa Thompson first some might steal
the show a lot of people seem to be
concluding that it's still Chris
Hemsworth's movie which I'm glad to hear
oh good yeah it should be a thorn in it
and I hear really does reinvigorate who
Thor is as a character it's important
that they do that because you know the
this the Thor
you know the thoracotomies are kind of
in the middle of the Marvel yeah beyond
reinventing the tone you gotta read
about the character along with the tone
which I'm excited for from what I'm
hearing everything just seems like it's
really well-balanced yeah because out of
this revenge errs group Tessa Thompson
is the new one we've already seen loki
before we already seen hope before he'll
about Mark Ruffalo is talking about I
gotta play two different people like
that we didn't do the whole talks more
but I'm sure I see the movie I'll be
like oh yeah get more what you're saying
what I've heard people raving about him
- you know yeah and the in Creole I
giving Hulk a substantial thing as you
know a focal yeah it's kind of like
Thor's Park oh yeah cuz it's let's make
him a buddy team I'm excited for that
in a weird way I feel like office what
was it called office Thor whenever was
said that that's short they really I
don't know I feel like kind of the
success of that sketch they put out with
him in his like room aid doing on office
things we have the success of that -
thank in a way but yeah that went over
really well it seems like everyone was
like
oh yes the words doing its own thing I
see them get to go to nutso with that
like well that was brilliant marketing
because it probably has nothing to do
with the actual movie itself it
establishes a tone and a different style
and a sense of humor that made us all go
I wish there was more like this well
somebody makes an office reference in
this video we watch and it made me think
directly of that I was like oh what if
we treated Thor like this was a day at
the mall yeah for Sam sir it just looks
like he's having a toy lady just really
have any fun never Avengers live and
he's so funny with that delivery yeah
and you know I don't care what people
say about the Ghostbusters reboot I
thought he was the stairs I mean I and I
think people who don't like that movie
can even agree that he is one of the
shining parts yeah he's hilarious and
shout out today for Tony McGuire over at
patreon we got to do a Google hangout
with this guy super SuperDuper friendly
dude he kind of has hair like me just a
little more beautiful and he lives in
your favorite place in the world a
Colorado and he has a mom who I think is
pretty birthday for that I've never seen
her but based on based off Tony's
description of her I'm going to assume
she's a hot mom so Tony's mom if you're
watching you have a good-looking son
these compliments are all over the place
but you use a de tourny McGuire man you
have a video game passion I hope you
pursued video games more often if I
pursue does that mean just buy them
don't actually pursue a career
who needs that just buy more video games
play then and then settle for some job
that you're miserable with for the rest
of your life oh the American Dream you
make Jesus always wanted at least
something more that's the American dream
well thor ragnarok keep a look out for
our review probably do a spoiler review
too because people will want that and we
only live to give people what they want
we don't self validate we only look for
external validation from people on the
internet we have never personally seen
or met just comment subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell you can follow us on social media
you can please keep a lookout for our
sketch
we were planning on having out by
Halloween telling you guys it's
definitely not gonna be monetized got
some graphic yeah
but we're really putting working our
asses off on this sketch right now and
the way we just really want you guys to
just watch it and share it if you really
like it would be perfect for Halloween
fun so yeah keep a lookout for that